that's me can you buzz me in
good for you
the three of you think you have
extraordinary gifts like something out
of a comic book I've developed an
effective treatment for this disorder
the light will force a different
identity to take away from the controls
so you're not gonna shake my hand and
let me walk out of here
[Music]
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went
only a few no our story changed the
world forever we have to fight for their
freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't nothing without your dragon
it's you and me bud always
[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes the
small just a beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
sure sad wait for real sigh okay
Shazam
you know I don't think that's gonna buff
out your co-stars your phone charge
he'll be like a bad guy right
I will prove it
you're dead sorry about your window
you're welcome for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
danos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
buzz for with
[Music]
okay
here's that good morning New York City
[Music]
what are you doing what's it look like
I'm doing
I'm doing superhero stuff
[Music]
Oh
and everywhere
I hope the class
but nah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey somebody get down before you die
[Music]
[Music]